HANK: Good morning, John, it's Friday.
JOHN: Good morning, Hank, it is indeed Friday!
Yes! That was a poor high five. Poor.
Today's video comes to you in three parts.
Part one...
HANK: ...an announcement. Part two...
JOHN: ...a challenge, and part three...
HANK: ...another announcement.
JOHN: That is different from the first announcement.
Part one, an announcement. The 2010 Project
for Awesome is happening.
HANK: It's on! You might remember in 2007
when John and I kind of realized that Nerdfighteria
had become a pretty big deal, and we wanted
to do something with the power that Nerdfighteria
wields.
JOHN: We decided to take over YouTube and
for one day, YouTube would not be about kittens
on Roombas, or about giraffe love, it would
be about charity.
HANK: And now for three years straight, we've
been doing this very successfully, and it's
been getting bigger and bigger every year...
JOHN: This year it's going to be the biggest
it has ever been.
HANK: By far.
JOHN: There's going to be a huge, epic live
show out of Los Angeles...
HANK: We just got off the phone with YouTube.
So YouTube's basically giving us the same
kind of treatment that like Conan O'Brien
and the president get where they're doing
a four hour live stream on YouTube.
JOHN: So there's going to be this big live
show, but there'll also be--<elbows Hank>
sorry...BAHHH! But there's also going to be
traditional P4A stuff, which means that hopefully,
all of you will upload amazing Project For
Awesome videos on December 17th. The thing
to do is to show us charities you care about
in action.
HANK: And I know this might sound weird, but
it might involve you getting out of your chair.
JOHN: You might have to leave your bedroom.
And that's not something either Hank or I
enjoy, and we are sympathetic to the fact
that it is no fun for you, but if it makes
for a better Project For Awesome video, it
therefore makes for a better universe. And
so...get out there!
HANK: So we're giving you some lead time this
time, you have three weeks before December
17th to plan and execute your video. And we
will be announcing more things in the future,
so give you subejuvevuv...
JOHN: That was very eloquent, at the end particularly.
I'm moved.
HANK: And we'll be giving you more details
as time goes on, like the thumbnail, and the
logo, and the websites, and et cetera.
JOHN: And for those of you who don't know
much about the Project For Awesome, you'll
find videos here, here, here and here, and
you'll also find some videos in the dooblydoo.
HANK: Part two! A challenge!
JOHN: We would like to challenge you, Nerdfighteria.
Last night at dinner, Hank and I were discussing
pasta.
HANK: Pasta and beef.
JOHN: Everyone knows that it is far more efficient
in terms of energy output to create pasta
than it is to create beef, and that remains
true even if you import the pasta from, say,
Italy...
HANK: But we were wondering, would this remain
true if you were importing the pasta from
somewhere farther away. Say like the moon.
JOHN: Like space.
HANK: So what we wanna know is, is it more
efficient to fly Apollo 11 to the moon, pick
up a load of pasta, fill up the capsule entirely
and then ship it back...would it then be more
energy intensive than growing a cow? Per calorie.
That is our question. We hope that there are
some of you who are nerdy and smart enough
to give us an accurate answer.
JOHN: Because we couldn't figure it out.
HANK: Nope!
JOHN: So we are turning to you, because you
never disappoint us. Nerdfighteria, if you
successfully determine for us whether moon
pasta is more efficient than earth beef, then
we will allow you to challenge us to do something
horrible. Part three...
HANK: The final announcement is that you may
have noticed that it is Black Friday. So in
the spirit of the holidays, DFTBA Records
is lowering prices on some new shirts and
some old favorites. Are you...putting bunny
ears...
JOHN: I was trying to but your head was too
high.
HANK: The new shirts are the giraffe love
shirt--
JOHN: Why are the shirts on my face!
HANK: Because that's where they go! Two new
DFTBA shirts, which we're calling the DFTBA
University shirts, and the Giant Squid of
Anger shirt, designed by amazing nerdfighter
Vondell Swain.
JOHN: Aaaghhhaaaagaaa! Alright so quick recap:
HANK: dftba.com/sale for all of your t-shirt
needs.
JOHN: Is it more efficient to have moon pasta
or earth burgers, and...
HANK: The Project for Awesome, December 17th,
get ready and be awesome. DFTBA, Nerdfighters,
he'll see you on Monday.
JOHN: ...I guess I'm Teller now.